témoignages très troublants.
- Six mois sous les tirs,
six mois d'occupation russe.
Izioum n'est plus que
désolation. Une plaie béante,
à l'image de ses habitants qui
sont restés. Repeindre les chars
et les camions russes,
pour effacer les traces
de leurs propriétaires,
le fameux Z, triste symbol
de l'opération russe,
ne suffira pas à faire oublier.
Irina Milous ne trouve plus
ses repères dans les ruines.
Elle a passé les six derniers
mois cachée chez elle,
terrorisée à l'idée que les
soldats russes trouvent les
affaires de son mari.
Il est au front,
elle ne sait plus où,
dans l'armée ukrainienne.
"Nous avons caché toutes ses
affaires, dot-elle, pour qu'ils
ne les trouvent pas.
Nous les avons enterrées.
Ils n'ont rien trouvé en lien
avec l'armée, alors ils ne nous
ont pas touchés. Mais nous
avions prcrcrcrce qu'ils sont
venus avec des armes."
C'est terrée dans ce petit
réduit au sous-sol de sa mai
que Katerina a vécu
l'occupation. Veuve, elle
n'était pourtant pas seule.
En mars, alors que les Russes
ve d d d d'occuper Izium,
son chien est venue l'alerté
en panique. En le suivant
dans le potager, elle a fait
une découverte choquante.
Un homme, qu'elle a cru mort,
gisait au pied d'un arbre.
"J'ai commencé à le
déshabiller. Il était
complètement noir, dit-elle.
Ses brass s s s mains avaient
été électocutées, son visage
était bleu, un de ses yeux
baignait dans le sang.
Ses jambes et ses pieds étaient
complètement noirs. Ils ont dû
le frapper avec des bâtons.
C'était horrible."
Katerina l'a soigné, nourri,
protégé alors même que
les soldatououououillaient
et pillaient son jardin.
Des soins constants qu'il a dû
prodiguer de nouveau quand une
partie du plafond s'est
affaissée à la suite
du bombardement.
"Qu s s s s'est effondré, dit-
elle, il était allongé là.
Le silence est tombé
à l'extérieur. Nous sommes
sortis, tout était en feu
dehors, tout brûlait. Et des
soldats sont venus en courant
avec des mitraillettes.
C'était horrible, horrible!"
Elle n'avait pas revu Misha,
qui est devenu un fils pour
elle, depuis la libération
d'Izioum, il y a une dizaine
de jours. Elle le retrouve
aujourd'hui, toujours faible,
alité chez lui.
(rires)
Misha montre comment un
des soldats, un tchétchène,écécé
la gorge avec un couteau.
Et pour expliquer pourquoi
il avait été emmené parles solde
ses papiers de l'armée.
Misha faisait partie de la
Défense territoriale d'Izioum.
"Ils me gardaient dans une
grange, raconte-il, où il y
avait un gros bloc de glace.
J'avais faim, j'avais soif.
et j'ai dû manger la glace.
C'est comme ça
qu'ils me gardaient."
Pendant 9 jours, il a subi
différentes tortures, raconte
Misha: électrocution, simulacre
de noyade. Au dixième jour,
il a été relâché dans les bois
près de la gare avec un tir dans
les airs en guise de menace.
"Je n'arrivais pas à faire
trois pas avant de tomber.
Trois pas, et je m'effondrais.
Je ne pouvais pas respirer,
j'avais perdu upupupup
de sang."
Impossible de voir un médecin.
Il doit tout à celle qu'il
appelle son ange, sa deuxième
mère. Une inconnue qui n'a pas
hésité une seconde à tout
risquer pour le sauver.
"Je ne serais pas ici sans
elle. Tout simplement.
Je ne pouvais plus marcher,
mais même si j'avais pu marcher
si loin, je n'aurais jamais
atteint la maison pour
une simple raison. J'étais
couvert de sang, je n'avais pas
de papiers d'identité et desenne
coin de rue. Je ne serais arrivé
nulle part."
Nulle part, sauf peut-être ici,
dans une fosse commu
découverte quand les soldats
ukraininens ont repris
la ville d'Izioum.
C'est l'odeur qui vous prend
à la gorge, avant de sais
l'ampleur de ce qui est
maintenant un cimetière à ciel
ouvert. Des dizaines
d'enquêteurs s'y activent entre
ceux dont la lourde tâche est
de déterrer chacun des corps.
Quelque 450 tombes
où s'empilent parfois deux ouoùu
une vingtaine de soldats
ukrainiens ont été retrouvés
entremêlés, selon les autorités
ukrainiennes. "L'étala
crimes de tortionnaires", a
dénoncé le président Zelinsky.
La preuve, selon la police,
que des crimes de guerre ont été
commis par lieieieie ici.
- I hate Russian Forces.
"Plusieurs corps ont été
retrouvés avec les mains
attachées dans le doc c c c des
cordes autour du cou, beaucoup
portait les marques de blessures
dans des explosions. Il y a des
corps qu'on sort de la terre
avec des membres écrasés
ou des membres amputés",
raconte ce policier.
L'objectif principal de ce
travail acharné, c'est bien sûr
de documenter de possibles
crimes de guerre. Mais tous ceux
qui ont été enterrés ici ne sont
pas nécessairement morts
de façon violente. Et pour
les famiuiuiuiui attendent de
récupérer les leurs, ce sont de
très longs moments d'angoisse.
Ils attendent patiemment
près d'une tente érigée dans
la forêt, face au spectacle,
dont la désolation n'a d'égale
que la puanteur.
Taïtia a le numéro 304,
qui marque le lieu où est
enterrée sa mèlelelele est
morte, pendant l'occupation,
de causes naturelles.
Si tant est qu'il est naturel
de mourir cachée dans une cave
pour échapper à la violence
des combats.
"Je veux enterrer ma mèredadaï.
Elle a besoin de ça. Je veux
aussi confirmer que son corps
est bien enterré ici et qu'il ne
s'agit pas seulement dméméméméro
qu'on m'a donné comme ça.
Je pourrais venir me recueillir
sur sa tombe et partager
un morceau de pain avec elle
pour me rappeler son âme."
Ça pourrait prendre des jours,
voire des semaines.
Chacun des corps exhumés devra
être autopsié pour déterminer
la cause du décès. Autant dire
une éternité pour ceux qui
ndndndndent. Le repos éternel
est encore bien loin à Izioum.
(chants et prière